Panic had set in.
Researchers were frantic.
There was a buzz of activity, not born of
excitement but from sheer, widespread fear.
The Scarlet King was coming.
Nobody at the Foundation knew when, or even
how, the monstrous multiversal tyrant would
spring free and bring endless chaos with him.
But everyone knew it would be soon.
They’d all had the same warning, the same
nightmare.
In fact, it wasn’t just the Foundation either;
the entire world had shivered in their sleep,
sharing in the bad dream of the destruction
that was yet to come.
The personnel of the SCP Foundation were on
high alert.
Of course, the organization had been aware
of the impending threat of the Scarlet King
for longer than almost anyone else.
But that was part of the problem: through
some anomalous dream, had by everyone on Earth,
now everyone else did know.
The Foundation was less interested in uncovering
the source of the nightmare, and more trying
to counteract its potential side effects.
That was what potentially offered the Scarlet
King the power he needed to enter into reality,
after all; the more people knew about him,
tried to understand or define the eldritch
entity, the more power he was able to obtain.
“We have an army!” one member of personnel
chimed in during a frantic debate.
“We have an almost unlimited fighting force
that are specially trained to handle anomalous
threats: the Mobile Task Forces!”
“Are you crazy?”
another argued.
“The MTFs are certainly not unlimited.
At any rate, the Scarlet King might be one
of the most powerful beings in the entire
multiverse!
How can our troops, even our anomalous units,
even hope to stand against that?
You’re proposing sending our own people
into a slaughter!”
“They’d all be wiped out in a moment,”
one of the other researchers concurred.
“We need to be focusing our efforts on the
amnestic rollout!
If we can distribute enough to the population,
we can wipe their collective memories of the
dream from the other night.
They’ll forget, and that should slow the
approach of the Scarlet King.”
“Slow him, maybe – but it won’t stop
him!”
the first retorted.
“Full-scale retaliation is still our best
option!
Even now, while we try to come up with a strategy,
that could be enough to draw him in.
We’re willing him into existence as we speak!”
“What about deploying another SCP?”
came a voice from the edge of the group.
It belonged to Junior Researcher Jake Harrison,
a relatively new member of the Foundation,
who had been reading up on files related to
the Scarlet King.
He knew that, in trying to understand and
come up with a way to best the murderous multiversal
warlord, that he was inadvertently feeding
him power.
But Jake seemed to have stumbled on the one
solution that everyone else had overlooked.
There was already another anomaly that might
have been perfectly suited for defeating the
Scarlet King…
“What do you suggest, Harrison?”
one of the other researchers spat.
“You really think something like SCP-682
would be willing to work with us and destroy
the Scarlet King?
That’s absurd!”
“I heard 682 is meant to be one of the Scarlet
King’s children!”
another remarked.
“No, not 682!”
Jake argued, turning to the researcher that
had just made a comment about the entity’s
supposed children; a group of anomalies that
were believed to have been born of the Scarlet
King himself.
“But you’re on the right track.
We use SCP-999.”
The group of researchers looked dumbfounded
at Jake.
He couldn’t tell if they were about to yell
at him, or if they would all burst out laughing.
To his surprise, they actually looked to be
considering his proposal.
It was widely believed that SCP-999 – the
adorable blob of orange slime known as the
Tickle Monster – was actually the final
child of the Scarlet King.
“That’s… not entirely implausible,”
one of the researchers answered.
“SCP-999 is believed to be an ultimate force
for good that could, in theory, defeat his
‘father’.”
“The Scarlet King is meant to be unparalleled
chaos, the two could cancel each other out,”
another theorized.
“But the Tickle Monster – sorry, I mean
SCP-999 – it’s still an infant, a child!”
someone else pointed out.
“Even if it could one day beat the Scarlet
King, it's nowhere near strong enough to yet.
We might have days, minutes even, before he
arrives, and I don’t know if 999 has the
power to stop his father.”
“Then what if we could make him stronger?”
Jake replied, a risky idea brewing in his
head.
“Surely you aren’t suggesting…”
Suddenly, a loud rumbling rang out, like an
earthquake, only much louder.
And instead of coming from the ground below,
the noise was coming from the sky.
The Foundation’s researchers raced to the
nearest window, or ran out of the buildings
they were in to turn their gazes upwards.
Scored across the sky above was a deep, blood-red
crack, a wound in the fabric of reality itself.
It was huge, almost covering one horizon to
the next, and everyone looking at it knew
what it meant.
That crack in the sky heralded the approach
of the Scarlet King.
Junior Researcher Harrison spent the next
hour impatiently trying to get hold of someone,
anyone who could approve his proposal.
The O5 Council were already swamped with suggestions
for how to stop the Scarlet King, each one
contributing to his rapid approach.
Eventually, Jake made it through and spoke
directly with a representative, an underling
for the O5 Council.
“Listen to me,” he urged.
“I know this isn’t your department, but
I need someone to sign off on this.
Please, the lives of everyone in this reality
could depend on it.”
“What are you proposing?”
“The Clockworks, SCP-914,” Jake answered.
“We place SCP-999 inside, speed up the process,
and make him strong enough to stop the Scarlet
King.”
It was an astronomical gamble, using the anomalous
improvement machine.
Constructed of a multitude of clockwork components
– cogs, gyros, gears – SCP-914 was a device
that could be used to enhance or ‘refine’
any object placed inside its ‘Input’ booth.
Depending on the setting, items could be transformed,
destroyed or vastly improved using the Clockworks.
‘Rough’ setting disintegrated any test
subject, while ‘Coarse’ dismantled it
to its base components.
‘1:1’ replaced any item with an almost
identical copy.
Then, there were the ‘Fine’ and ‘Very
Fine’ settings, the former would cause SCP-914
to improving any item and the latter capable
of the same but with one key difference.
‘Very Fine’ would refine an object even
more, usually by giving it anomalous properties.
Jake had read up on SCP-914, and knew that
the Foundation had permitted researchers to
conduct tests using the machine.
However, following a catastrophic test, nothing
organic could be tested in SCP-914.
That was a strict rule, no biological organism
or living thing of any description was to
be placed within the Clockworks.
It was Jake’s hope, however, that desperate
times called for desperate measures.
Surely, with the Scarlet King almost upon
them, the Council would waive the restriction
and allow SCP-999 to undergo refinement.
The O5 Council representative’s voice cut
out after Jake made his suggestion.
There was a long pause, even without the pressure
of incoming calamity, the silence seemed to
extend for a painfully long time.
Suddenly, someone else spoke up in their place,
a modulated, distorted voice.
It quickly became clear to Jake he was talking
directly to a member of the O5 Council.
Under a different set of circumstances, he
might have felt honored, but right now it
was almost as scary as the threat of destruction
by the Scarlet King.
“Listen closely, Junior Researcher,” the
council member said on the other end of the
comm line.
“You may think you understand SCP-914, you
may even think that it might aid us in stopping
the current crisis.
But you are far, far mistaken.
You will cease this course of action immediately;
your proposal has been denied.”
“But wait!”
Jake protested.
“Surely it could work!
I know biological material isn’t permitted
inside the Clockworks, but that doesn’t
mean it can’t affect living matter.
SCP-999 is a living organism.
If he really is everything that we think he
is, and if we just put him through the refinement
process, he could-”
“No, Researcher Harrison!”
the voice barked.
“Using the Clockworks would mean we risk
losing SCP-999.”
“What are you talking about?”
“You appear to have a fundamental misunderstanding
of SCP-914, Junior Researcher,” the council
member chastised.
“It doesn’t merely improve upon existing
objects, but replaces them with a new version
it creates.
If we were to place SCP-999 inside, the creature
as we know it would be gone forever, and – if
it really is capable of stopping this catastrophe
– we will then have lost our ultimate weapon
against the Scarlet King.”
“But, but-” Jake tried to say.
“Enough!
Every second we waste discussing our options,
the more power the Scarlet King is able to
amass.”
“So why don’t we stop talking about it
and actually do something!”
the young researcher shouted, giving in to
his frustration and losing his temper.
The comm line went dead, there was no one
on the other end anymore.
Another rumbling sound rippled through the
building, even louder than the last tremor.
Jake ran towards a nearby window and looked
out in horror: it was already too late.
The red crack above had split open wider,
and like a tidal wave, hordes of nightmarish
creatures came spilling out, raining down
on the world.
At commanding them, sending forth his minions
in a flood of destruction, was the Scarlet
King himself.
Jake was done waiting for permission from
the Council.
He sprinted as fast as he could through the
facility, past panicking researchers fleeing
for their lives, while security officers and
MTF troops abandoned their posts in the futile
hope they could survive the end of this reality
and all others.
Jake forced himself not to pay attention:
he needed to find SCP-999.
The playful blob was often free to roam around
the facility, improving the days of anyone
it encountered.
So, all Jake needed to do was find anyone
who seemed happy despite the catastrophe,
and SCP-999 wouldn’t be far away.
Outside, the world began to resemble the nightmare
that everyone had experienced the night before.
Cities were burning as monstrous abominations
tore through innocent civilians, and ripped
buildings and cars to shreds, reducing every
nearby standing structure to little more than
rubble with frightening speed and ease.
The Scarlet King and his armies had been waiting
for this moment for centuries, millennia,
aeons even, and now nothing could stop them
from unfurling pure, indulgent chaos on this
reality.
They had their work cut out for them, subjugating
and destroying the entire multiverse, but
that isn’t to say they weren’t enjoying
it.
People across the Earth were being killed
in droves in the name of the Scarlet King.
He diverted a significant portion of his forces
to attacking the SCP Foundation itself.
While the boots on the ground MTF troops – the
ones that had remained loyal – were usually
a formidable fight, they were no match for
the eldritch armies of the Scarlet King.
The horde began to set free other anomalies
kept locked up in containment, either by accident
when they stormed the Foundation’s facilities,
or intentionally seeking out their cells to
spring them.
Some SCPs tried to stand up to the Scarlet
King and fight back.
The likes of the Plague Doctor, The Specter,
and SCP-2800 all tried their best to ward
off the oncoming attacks of the Scarlet King’s
foot soldiers.
They lasted longer than those who decided
instead to run away, turning heel and trying
in vain to escape the destructive reach of
the Scarlet King.
Even anomalies like SCP-106, who could escape
to other plains of existence or pocket dimensions,
weren’t safe.
In hiding, they were only prolonging the inevitable:
the Scarlet King would find them all; no corner
of the multiverse was safe.
And, of course, some SCPs thrived in the catastrophe.
Creatures like SCP-682, the infamous Hard
to Destroy Reptile, found themselves free
to exact revenge on the Foundation and humanity
at large.
Of these, not all the anomalies gave away
their allegiance – 682 in particular was
too busy killing anything it came into contact
with, whether they were human or a part of
the Scarlet King’s army.
But other SCPs gladly swore fealty with the
crimson cosmic conqueror, forming alliances
with the entity responsible for setting them
loose and joining the mass of monstrosities
he had unleashed.
And yet, in the midst of all the chaos, the
calamity, and the millions upon millions of
deaths, one Junior SCP Foundation Researcher
was still searching for the wholesome orange
blob.
Jake Harrison had put all his chips on SCP-999,
and eventually tracked the Tickle Monster
down.
The building around him was crumbling, attacks
from the Scarlet King and his minions bombarding
every second.
As Jake ran into the mess hall, his eyes instantly
caught sight of the ball of orange slime,
cowering under a table.
“Hey, hey!” he whispered, hoping to coax
it out.
“It’s okay, I know there’s a lot going
on right now.
Hell, it’s the end of the world outside.
But if you come with me, I think we can fix
it together!
Come on, little guy, what do you say?”
As if in reply, SCP-999 immediately leaped
up out of its hiding place.
Jake caught it in his arms, instantly feeling
a wave of calm wash over him thanks to the
Tickle Monster’s calming anomalous effect.
He tried to stop himself from fully succumbing
to the good vibes that the gelatinous creature
provided, after all, he still had a job to
do, and time was short.
The Scarlet King and his invading army might
have seemed, for the most part, to be indulging
in wanton destruction, decimating cities and
Foundation sites, killing humans left, right,
and center.
But Jake figured that, if there was any method
to their madness, then SCP-999 would be at
the very center of it.
Not even the Scarlet King knew for certain
if SCP-999 really was his offspring.
Maybe he had heard the rumors and wanted to
reach the Tickle Monster just before it had
a chance to stop him, if it even could.
If the Scarlet King believed, even for a second,
that his supposed son stood a chance at defeating
him and ending his reign of terror, then he’d
waste no time hunting the orange blob down.
His army of nightmarish creatures would comb
every corner of the world until they found
SCP-999.
Although they might not think to look inside
the Clockworks.
Placing the smiling, slimy SCP in the Input
booth, Jake fiddled with the controls for
SCP-914.
He’d never performed any experiments using
the machine before, but it was all pretty
self-explanatory, throwing the dial to ‘Very
Fine’.
He gave a moment’s pause, looking at the
adorable anomaly in the machine.
The warning from the Council rang in his ears:
if he activated the Clockworks, he’d, in
effect, be killing SCP-999.
Either that, or the Scarlet King would do
it himself when he found the Tickle Monster.
Neither scenario ended well.
Then, the thundering sounds of the massacre
outside got louder, screams coming from innocent
people who were being caught in the Scarlet
King’s carnage.
There was no question about it: if what Jake
was about to do really could stop all this
mayhem, then it was worth replacing SCP-999
to do it.
With a deep breath, he flipped the switch.
The clicking and clacking of the Clockworks’
components whirring into life were drowned
out by the approaching tremors.
Something was coming…
no, he was coming, Jake thought.
The very fabric of the building around him
started shaking, brickwork and cement crumbling
and falling apart as a large hand, fingers
ending in pointed, crimson claws, wrenched
open the roof with ease.
Looking up in horror, Jake saw that the sky
was a dark shade of red.
Towering over it, a colossal crimson-clad
warrior looked in on the frightened researcher,
horns protruding from its head.
Maybe because SCP-999 was still nearby, the
blob was offering him some kind of positive
mental protection.
Otherwise, the mere sight of the gigantic
monstrous being above him would have driven
Jake and any other mortal mad.
The Scarlet King was upon him.
“WHERE IS HE?” came a booming voice that
sounded like hundreds of screams overlaying
each other.
The Scarlet King’s gaze seemed to shift
slightly, turning from Jake as he lay helplessly
on the ground, to look at SCP-914.
The machine had fully activated, and couldn’t
be stopped now.
Either through foreknowledge, or some kind
of cosmic sense, the eldritch monstrosity
seemed to know exactly what the device did.
“No…
no!
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE?”
the Scarlet King roared.
He raised a gargantuan fist, and brought it
straight down through the air towards Jake.
He couldn’t run, the Scarlet King was so
vast in size that there was no way the researcher
would be able to evade the oncoming strike.
Jake raised his arms in a futile attempt to
protect himself, despite knowing that the
Scarlet King’s fist would likely plunge
through the very surface of the Earth below.
But then again, maybe the junior researcher
just didn’t want to watch.
There was a pause.
The strike never came.
It was only when Jake built up the courage
to open his eyes that he saw what had happened.
A long tendril of orange slime had reached
out of SCP-914, forming a protective barrier
between Jake at the Scarlet King.
Suddenly, with all the force of a tidal wave,
the newly refined SCP-999 came pouring out
of the Clockworks.
The Tickle Monster’s mass had increased,
he was thousands, if not millions of times
bigger.
Swept aside and out of harm's way by the orange
slime, the junior researcher looked up in
amazement as SCP-999 reached up into the sky,
able to look its supposed father face to face.
The Scarlet King recoiled in horror as the
Tickle Monster engulfed him, pulling the cosmic,
crimson plunderer into an embrace.
As they hugged, there seemed to be a change
in the Scarlet King.
The eldritch monster had spent all his time,
since the dawn of creation, as a cruel, nihilistic
conqueror.
He had killed and enslaved, devoured ancient
gods, and slaughtered entire planes of existence
in his quest to annihilate everything.
But now, held tight by his gelatinous son,
his heart shifted.
It was as if the Scarlet King’s eyes had
been opened, and he could see the beauty of
creation.
The sheer, overwhelming goodness of SCP-999,
enhanced by SCP-914, undid the evil of the
Scarlet King himself.
Only it didn’t stop.
As the orange slime engulfed the Scarlet King
in a hug, he began to be unmade.
The Tickle Monster, without even trying to
harm its father, had been made into such a
beacon of pure positivity by the Clockworks
that the Scarlet King simply ceased to exist.
He was unwoven, not killed but rendered without
any purpose.
He barely even felt any pain, but at the same
time, was removed from this and every other
universe.
And still, it didn’t stop.
The newly recreated SCP-999 spread across
the world like an orange flood.
The Scarlet King’s armies, the other SCPs,
even the few surviving human beings were all
wiped away, SCP-999 spread to every corner
of the Earth, turning the blue planet orange
as he coated it, purging every single scrap
of negativity.
All hatred, all cruelty, all evil – even
that of the SCP Foundation itself.
The entire world was unmade by the Tickle
Monster, not out of malice, but so that nobody
anywhere could cause the Scarlet King to remerge.
At the same time, all that was left was a
planet-sized ball of orange slime, lonelily
spinning through space.
Now go and check out “SCP-999 THE TICKLE
MONSTER” for more information on everyone’s
favourite orange blob of wholesomeness or
“CHILDREN OF SCP-001 THE SCARLET KING – IS
SCP-999 REALLY HIS SON?”, and explore their
bizarre family tree.